Ryan is in Roanoke Virginia
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show run how
are you alright Dave how you doing
better than I deserve
what's up I was wondering if I should
take out a loan to consolidate all my
party cards you can how much credit card
debt if you got about $17,000 okay and
what is your interest rates one credit
card is four percent and the other two
are twenty and twenty two percent okay
what's the how much what's the balance
on the four percent about eight thousand
dollars okay so half of its at four
percent have you been offered a
consolidation loan my bank is currently
offering a secured loan with an interest
rate of 3.6% secures not what I was
thinking of a secured by what are
secured by them no a secured loan has
collateral that you're putting up
something with a lien on it are they
taking a loan on your house a lien on
your car a lien on a bank account what
it would be my husband
okay all right and what is your income
sir my take-home income is about $12,000
a year okay why are you a student I
worked full-time in retail actually my
wife does the same
what's your household income $24,000
coming into a house okay all right you
got a couple of lousy jobs don't you yes
we did I'm trying to change that I'm not
picking on you I'm just going dude I
think you can make more money you make
more money delivering pizzas and you're
making right now you're working 40 hours
at retail yes sir
how old are you 38 years old
okay I did 10 years in the army
I got out of the army two years ago and
unfortunately this is the only thing
that's happened so far in my life gotcha
okay well I think more than a credit
card crisis you have an income crisis
and I think you would agree with me
because you were already looking to do
better and I mean I truthfully you can
deliver pizzas and make more money than
you're making now you make 1,500 bucks a
month delivering pizza at night that's
$18,000 a year and that's just doing it
at night
now obviously you got to take your
retail if you've got evening shifts
you'd have to take those off but you
make more but that's all a temporary
stopgap what I want you to do is say
what am I going to be doing when I'm 48
that makes me not $12,000 a year but
makes me $65,000 a year whatever number
you pick up a number that's a lot more
and what are the steps I've got to do to
get to my get myself into that career
what have I got to learn that I don't
know what skills have I got to develop
that I don't know do I need to take a
class a certification I don't care what
do you want to be in the next phase of
your life and what are the steps to get
there that makes you more money that's
the big deal now here's the thing you
cannot borrow your way out of debt I
would not take out a credit card
consolidation loan on your home you're
taking an unsecured debt that's very
small and turning it into a secured debt
against your home I don't want this lien
against your home especially with your
income as low as it is right now I'm
going to leave it alone here's the it
let's say that you guys could do
something to increase your income pretty
dramatically and you clear this debt or
a lot of it within a couple of years the
amount of money you save on interest on
half of your loan because really only
half of its savings half of it $8,000 of
the 17 is it 4% so the other half is
really what's expensive and so really
you're going you got eight thousand
bucks that you're saving about a
thousand dollars a year in interest on
$1,000 a year is not your problem
on 17,000 dollars worth of debt what you
need is seventeen thousand dollars more
and that's where we go back to the
income side the
the working part-time jobs six of them
selling everything in sight and working
your long-term career choices and
decisions but you know we tell you to
list your debts smallest to largest and
attack them in that order so oddly
enough your smallest debts are your
highest interest rate debts in your case
and so that first $9,000 worth of debt
that you pay off will be the 20%
interest stuff because it's the smaller
debts than the 8,000 at 4% and so we
list our debt smallest to largest
regardless of interest rate in your case
it happens to be also correlating
properly with the interest rate and you
just attack and go in that order from
this point forward go right on down the
list and make sure you know what's going
on so that that's what I would do I
would spend 90% of my efforts right now
on developing income for the short term
with extra part-time jobs six of them
whether it's dog walking cutting grass
delivering pizzas
I don't care maybe you're an Internet
expert and you start building websites
for people I don't care but we're gonna
do side hustle or some kind hustling
ground hustling ground we're gonna sell
stuff and then long term we're gonna get
your incomes way up because we're gonna
really really really focus on what that
long term career is and what are the
steps to move into it that makes you
four or five times what you make now
because you're you know the biggest
thing you're facing here is not a big
pile of debt it's a lack of income in
your situation and again please hear me
that's not to shame you I appreciate
your service to the country I want you
to go win hold on I'm gonna send you a
copy of the book the Total Money
Makeover which will walk you through
exactly what to do how to do it and
where we go from here thanks for the
call